the jurogan experience that's a big
issue with uh perceptions of people who
don't hunt right
non-hunters perceptions are a lot of
times based on grip and grins
there are a lot of times based on maybe
you're flipping through the channels and
you get on the outdoor channel and some
guy shoots a big buck and they're
hooting and hollering and high-fiving
each other
and people find it distasteful like they
they see it
and they don't understand why everyone's
so excited and so happy
because they don't see how difficult it
is to get to that position
how much anxiety is involved in
shot placement and squeezing the trigger
making sure you don't flinch and
it's it's hard like any kind of hunting
and taking an animal's life is very
difficult so when you see that that
success celebration people think it's
like a celebration of
of death of killing right but it's a
celebration of success and of overcoming
anxiety and nervousness and
and the the fear of failure and this the
moment itself
which is so enormous the moment when
you're squeezing a trigger
or drawing back a bow on an animal it's
a heavy moment
yeah and there's so much so much going
on in the mind
somewhat so much anxiety that you have
to battle
well and i think too that it's it's a
snippet of time that's taken completely
out of context
yeah and you don't see the lifestyle
potentially that and there's all
gradients and
and scale inside of hunters you know
some some people it truly is a lifestyle
they've dedicated their life to it
others
you know do it less time whatever but
like
when i see a griffin grin photo i see a
lifestyle i see somebody that's probably
dedicated a big part of their life
that's not even connected directly to
hunting
that has informed their ability to be
efficient hunters that's kind of what
the stories that i'm telling
and and even in the future some of the
stuff i'm planning in the future
what i'm trying to tell the story of is
is people who live their lives close to
the land
and the other things that happen so you
always hear
some flavor of hunting in most of my
podcasts
many of them are not about hunting at
all
but you'll you'll see a small window but
you'll see this light for instance
there's a podcast that's coming out soon
and and i interview this old guy that
really is a legendary hunter i'm not
going to tell you where he's from i
don't want to forecast what the podcast
is about but
he the whole podcast is about his life
very little of it's about hunting but it
puts it in context
and it goes no that's not just a old
hillbilly out
shooting stuff this guy has dedicated
his life
to this this is a very thoughtful
process
this this guy not not just his life his
dad's life
and his dad's life before him was
dedicated i mean these guys made a
decision this is going to be a big part
of our life boys we're going to be
hunters and
it affected their careers it affected
their families it affected how many kids
they i mean
you know just like the implications of
choosing a lifestyle
is so big and that's what i think is so
profound about hunting and that's what
i'm interested in
is because i love to hunt like i cannot
erase that for me like i do love to hunt
but i am very interested in
where like how hunting has actually
affected my life
how it impacts the character of my
children
how it impacts the the the
sanctity of my marriage yeah i mean i
i'm kind of going out there but i'm
being serious
like i think that what we choose to
dedicate our life to
has the opportunity to make us better
and impact our character and
it's just a big story man it's a big
story and a grip and grin doesn't tell
that story
but it's so hard because it's hard to
tell me clay don't post a picture of
yourself with a dead deer and you
smiling
right it's like bro you want me to
accommodate my entire life
for you i will do that like i spend much
of my life
doing that trying to interpret for
people hunting
but we're kind of asking for some
for some empathy too from the other side
and
and we've got to do a better job of
telling our story yeah i think there's
that and there's also that we're
connected to
what you would call what the general
population would call trophy hunters
it's like that and that's therein lies
the rub with bears
is that many people don't understand
that bears are food
and that it's not just food it's
actually a delicious food and
from a conservation standpoint it's
actually important to control the
population
but when you see someone posing with an
animal
unfortunately it will go to like
elephants
or giraffes or some some
unpleasant animal a lion where you see
someone posing with a lion and then you
think about some
canned hunt in africa where some obese
man is standing there with a
with a rifle over this majestic animal
and it's very distasteful
yeah and it infuriates people and
rightly so because
like the image they're getting out of
that is some cruel
sociopath who's just trying to check off
boxes
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience